NORMAN : Aujourd'hui on joue aux jeux vidéo avec mon père
PÈRE : Bah je suis pas ton père
NORMAN : Ah bon?
PÈRE : Bah non je t'ai adopté
NORMAN : *Pleure*
PÈRE : "A" c'est avancer,
"B" c'est freiner, et "A" ?
NORMAN: C'est avancer
NORMAN : c'est parti, là je te vois.
Donc là, t'es en sens inverse
PÈRE : Ça donne le tournis quand même, hein?
NORMAN : T'as roulé sur une banane
PÈRE: *rires* J'me suis planté sur une banane alors...
En? Parce que banane plantain...
NORMAN: Bon écoute, moi je suis arrivé premier donc là je vais te regarder jouer...
PÈRE : Ben faut être rapide quand même, en?
NORMAN : Donc tu t'es dis là, tiens? Je vais pas avancer
Je vais rester vraiment immobile
PÈRE : Ah! oui oui oui oui...
NORMAN: Faut vraiment que tu restes sur la route
*beatbox* Arrivé!
Je suis très fier de toi. C'est ta première game, et t'es arrivé quand même heu...
Ben t'es arrivé!
PÈRE : et c'est quoi les cubes en glace, là, je sais pas quoi?
NORMAN : donc les les cubes en glaces c'est des petits cadeaux
Allez, moi je vais t'attendre et je vais te faire une surprise...
Attention
PERE : Ah, j'ai repris la piste. Voilà...voilà...
NORMAN : Allez ! C'est moi qui t'ai jeté ça. Excellent !
j'adore tirer sur les faibles, c'est un vrai plaisir.
PERE : en fait je me sens handicapé
NORMAN : ah...
PERE : ouai c'est comme si je suis handicapé...
NORMAN : je te rassure t'es pas du tout handicapé
t'es juste un peu vieux...hahaha ALLEZ !
PERE : j'ai l'impression d'avoir changé de, de siècle
NORMAN : et toi c'était quoi ton jeu vidéo préféré quand t'étais petit ?
PERE : le flipper
NORMAN : ok donc pas un jeu vidéo.
PERE : aaah non... pas vraiment *norman rit*
PERE : et toi tu peux parler, discuter ?
NORMAN : moi chuis vraiment un pro gamer
PERE : dans la vraie vie je peux faire des trucs dans ma voiture
téléphoner par exemple... *sirènes de police*
PERE : dans la vraie vie je maîtrise bien ma voiture, c'est ça qui est bizarre...
NORMAN : Donc ça c'est un autre jeu tu vas voir, très simple
PERE : ah ouai on marche doucement c'est bien
NORMAN : bon ça a pas commencé encore, ça c'est une cinématique
PERE : et toi tu es Luigi toi ?
NORMAN : ouai, Luigi babe
PERE : ok et Mario eeeuh /NORMAN : mario babe...
PERE : ok HOP ! HOP il saute
et on saute pourquoi ?
*rires*
NORMAN : ba là par contre tu peux taper dans les caisses
PERE : ah oui si on tape dans les caisses, ah j'ai raté !
PERE : ah y'a un tuyau HOP ! HOP voilà
NORMAN : apparemment t'aimes, toi t'aimes les tuyaux hein...
c'est vraiment TON truc *rires*
PERE : On se sent handicapé, toujours la même chose *norman rit*
je sais pas ou je suis là... chuis dans ma bulle
PERE : dans ma bulle quoi !
NORMAN : dans ma bulle c'était un...album de Diam's
PERE : qui est devenu eeeum monastique
NORMAN : qui est devenu musulmane on peut en parler hein
NORMAN : aller ! perçons l'abcès elle est devenue musulmane
PERE : voila c'est pas un moine c'est une musulmane
PERE : haa j'étais pas loin regarde ! *norman crie*
PERE : bah ça a claqué.
*norman fait du beatbox*
NORMAN : ok c'est parti !
NORMAN : ça veut dire... /PERE : du caca dans l'oeil
NORMAN : du caca, on parle de caca /PERE : je peux te parler en Lingala si tu veux
NORMAN : tu sais parler le Lingala ? /PERE : ouais
PERE : *prononce un mot* c'est "bonjour". Je parle deux mots
PERE : *prononce un autre mot* ça veut dire...
je crois ça veut dire euh "connard" *rit*
NORMAN : d'accord bon... tu sais dire "bonjour connard" quoi c'est euh...
PERE : c'est tout ce que je peux dire. /NORMAN : donc tu arrives là-bas "bonjour connard !" *rires*
NORMAN : c'est vraiment le seul truc que tu peux faire
PERE : bah toi t'es jamais intéressé par les filles blacks toi ?
NORMAN : ah... tu veux vraiment qu'on parle de ça avec la caméra allumée
*rires*
NORMAN : c'est vraiment un sujet de discussion que tu veux aborder ?
PERE : bah oui quoi ? /NORMAN : moi j'aime tous les types de femmes
PERE : toutes les couleurs /NORMAN : tant qu'elles acceptent.
*le père de norman bafouille et éternue*
NORMAN : donc toi tu fais pause quoi... y'a pas de soucis *rires*
NORMAN : on part sur une pause.  /PERE : mais je...
NORMAN : vas-y, pourquoi t'appuies sur pause ?! / PERE : ah mince
NORMAN : monte la marche / PERE : ah oui il faut que je saute ! d'accord oui
NORMAN : allez, oh il refait pause !
PERE : pause ! attends on va dé-pauser (jeu de mot) / NORMAN : cet homme adore faire pause !
NORMAN : attends mais t'as beaucoup plus de points que moi !
c'est un truc de ouf / PERE : non
NORMAN : t'es totalement premier
putain je suis dégoûté je quitte
je quitte le plateau ! OH
NORMAN : j'ai quatre cloches / PERE : et moi je sais pas où je suis moi
NORMAN : vas-y il faut que tu prennes toutes les pièces MAINTENANT ! Comme à Fort Boyard
*générique de Fort Boyard*
PERE : pfff je sais pas où je suis... / NORMAN : bah t'es le mec avec une couronne
NORMAN : t'es Mario / PERE : ah d'accord Mario
PERE : je saute, bah pourquoi il y a plus les petites voitures là ?
NORMAN : bah c'est plus Mario Kart ça c'est
un autre jeu ça.
PERE : ah d'accord c'est pas mélangé
NORMAN : je vais faire une petite technique Spiderman, PAM (x5)
on a finis le troisième stage
*norman souffle* / PERE : i the winner
NORMAN : "i the winner" / PERE : non "i am the winner" *norman répète*
NORMAN : il faut tirer le requin comme ça
et le faire manger les pièces
PERE : on joue sur la même "plaquette" tous les deux ?
NORMAN : ouais, la même plaquette comme tu dis. *rires*
TOUS LES DEUX : la plaquette Ipad
NORMAN : très très belle plaquette
PERE : je suis passé au dessus de la baignoire *norman rit*
NORMAN : HOP LA allez ! on l'a déjà fait ce niveau  / PERE : mais c'est un peu euh...
PERE : surréaliste hein comme truc / NORMAN : pourquoi ?
PERE : bah tirer une coude à un requin pour bouffer des pièces...
*rires*
NORMAN : on dit merci aux internautes
PERE : ah bah oui merci / NORMAN : merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo / PERE : ciao ciao
NORMAN : et si quelqu'un veut se mesurer à mon père
je crois qu'il est OP !
*rires*  NORMAN : il s'en bat les couilles.
NORMAN  : ALLER CIAO !
*beatbox*
extrait spectacle de Norman : y'a plein de métiers où tu peux pas employer les guillemets
tu vas faire...bah je me présente c'est moi votre "chirurgien"
ouai je vais m'occuper personnellement de votre...
"greffe du cœur".